hello everyone and welcome to mel
simplified i'm dr umar malik and in this
video we will discuss about a few signs
that can indicate you have a kidney
disease
before we dive deeper into the topic
let me tell you a few very interesting
facts about our kidneys
the average kidney is as big as a cell
phone and weighs around 110 to 170 grams
now for children born with renal
agenesis which means only a single
kidney this single kidney grows till it
has the combined weight of two kidneys
nephrons are the filtering units of the
kidneys and each kidney has between 1 to
2 million nephrons
if the nephrons in the kidneys are
removed and laid end to end they cover a
distance of approximately 10 miles
kidneys perform the wild function of
generating vitamin d in our body now
this is primarily done by the skin on
exposure to sunlight but our kidneys
play a vital role further in the pathway
of vitamin d production
now let's talk about the basic functions
of our kidneys
kidneys are one of the most important
and busy organs in our body they are
basically like the filters for our blood
each kidney contains millions of these
tiny nephrons which are the functional
units of the kidneys
millions of nephrons act together and
these act as filters which work
continuously to filter the blood and
take out all the waste elements in the
blood broadly speaking there are three
major functions of our kidneys
removing waste from blood in the form of
urine
maintaining the chemical and fluid
balance of our body
and the third major function of a kidney
is that they help in regulating the
blood pressure
and also promote the growth of red blood
cells as they produce a hormone known as
erythropoietin
there are many other functions of our
kidneys but discussing them will make
the video too long
let me know in the comment section if
you want to see a detailed video about
the function of our kidneys
so coming back to the topic let's talk
about some of the reasons of kidney
problems and due to various reasons
kidneys can become unable to filter the
waste products from your blood
when this happens dangerous levels of
wastes may accumulate and your blood's
chemical levels may get out of balance
so there can be many reasons due to
which our kidneys may not be working
properly
this can be due to kidney damage due to
some reason or chronic kidney failure
due to some long term kidney disease
like prolonged diabetes or chronic high
blood pressure also known as
hypertension
other reasons include kidney damage due
to prolonged use of medications such as
aspirin ibuprofen and certain
chemotherapy drugs and antibiotics
chronic kidney infections and severe
allergic reactions can also lead to
kidney failure cholesterol deposits or
blood clots that block the blood flow in
the kidney can also lead to acute damage
in the kidneys
glomerular nephritis which is basically
the inflammation of the tiny filters in
the kidney also leads to kidney problems
and autoimmune disorders like sle also
lead to many cases of kidney failure
these autoimmune disorders also include
skin and connective tissue disorders
like scleroderma
other reasons can include accidental
ingestion of toxins
chronic alcohol use and cocaine abuse
urinary blockage in the kidneys due to
cancer enlarged prostate and stones are
some other reasons
now it is estimated that more than 37
million american adults are living with
kidney disease and most don't even know
about it as kidney failure doesn't
produce symptoms in the early stages of
the disease
according to the national kidney
foundation there are number of physical
signs of kidney diseases
but most people attribute them to other
conditions
also those with kidney diseases tend not
to experience symptoms until the very
late stages and the kidneys are failing
or when there are large amounts of
protein in the urine
this is one of the reasons why only 10
of the people with chronic kidney
disease know that they have the disease
so here are 10 physical signs of kidney
disease
keep in mind that these are not
diagnostic of kidney disease so before
diagnosing yourself always report your
symptoms to a physician and let him do
the diagnosis and treatment
number one you're more tired you have
less energy and you have trouble in
concentration
a severe decrease in kidney function can
lead to a buildup of toxins and
impurities in the blood
this can cause people to feel tired weak
and can make it hard to concentrate
another complication of kidney disease
is anemia which is a decrease in your
red blood cell number
this anemia can also cause weakness and
fatigue
number two
you have trouble sleeping
when the kidneys aren't filtering your
blood properly toxins accumulate in the
blood rather than leaving the body
through the urine
this can make it difficult to sleep
leading to insomnia
to make matters worse sleep apnea is
also more common in people with chronic
kidney disease compared with general
population
number three you have dry and itchy skin
healthy kidneys do many important job
apart from waste removal
they help in making red blood cells help
in keeping bones strong and they work to
maintain the right amount of minerals in
your blood
dry and itchy skin is a sign that the
mineral balance has been disturbed
it also indicates that the kidneys are
not effectively protecting your bones
due to inefficient management of calcium
levels
number four you may feel the need to
urinate more often
if you feel the need to urinate more
often especially at night this can also
be a sign of kidney disease
the kidney is a filter for impurities
but most of the fluid it filters is
reabsorbed
this is important to maintain a water
balance to prevent excess fluid loss
when the kidneys get damaged this
process of resorption is affected
this causes an increased urge to
maturate more than usual
but this sign can be commonly seen in
many other problems also most commonly
being the urinary tract infection
this too can also be a sign of an
enlarged prostate in elderly men
number five
you see blood in your urine
as i have mentioned earlier healthy
kidneys are highly efficient filters due
to the millions of nephrons it contains
when filtering wastes from the blood to
create urine the nephrons make it sure
to keep the blood cells in the body
but when the kidneys filters get damaged
these blood cells can start to leak out
in the urine
blood in the urine can also be
indicative of tumors kidney stones or an
infection in the kidney
number 6 your urine is foamy
nephrons do everything in their power to
keep the proteins in your body from
leaving via the urine
so if you see excessive bubbles in the
urine especially those that require you
to flush several times before they go
away it typically can indicate that
there is protein in the urine this means
your nephrons are damaged and are not
working properly
now this foam may look like the form you
see when scrambling eggs as a common
protein found in urine is albumin which
is the same protein that is found in the
eggs
this may look like a very simple finding
but it is not
proteins in the urine are actually one
of the most specific signs that your
kidneys are in some kind of trouble
number seven
important physical signs that may
indicate that you have a kidney problem
is that you are experiencing persistent
puffiness around your eyes and feet
presence of protein in the urine is an
early sign that the kidneys filters have
been damaged
allowing protein to leak into the urine
this puffiness or swelling around your
eyes and feet can be due to the fact
that your kidneys are leaking a large
amount of protein in the urine rather
than keeping it in the body
also decreased kidney function can lead
to sodium retention this sodium causes
more water to be saved in your
subcutaneous tissues this causes
swelling in your feet and ankles
swelling in your lower extremities can
also be a sign of heart disease liver
disease and chronic leg vein problems
number eight you often experience muscle
cramps
kidneys regulate your electrolyte levels
these electrolytes such as calcium
sodium potassium and phosphorus play a
very important role in maintaining
bodily functions
one of those crucial functions is
controlling muscle function so any
imbalance in these electrolyte levels
will affect muscle function directly and
lead to cramping stiffness pain and
weakness
for example low calcium levels and
poorly controlled phosphorus levels may
contribute to muscle cramps
well friends with this we come to the
end of this video if you find that you
or someone you know is having these
symptoms that i have mentioned earlier
please reach out to your health care
provider as soon as possible
kidney damage if diagnosed in the early
stages is preventable and full recovery
is possible in most of the cases your
healthcare provider will use a series of
tests such as blood work urine
examination kidney function tests and
radiological procedures such as
ultrasound and cd scans to diagnose and
manage your condition better
do not self-diagnose or try to
self-medicate as it can have serious
consequences for everyone involved
if you like this video share it with
your friends and don't forget to like
and subscribe
you can support us through our patreon
channel or also by becoming a member of
our channel on youtube
before i go i just want to tell you how
grateful i am for your continued love
and support
i'll see you in the next video take care
member bye